on monday's wwe raw roman reigns emerged
victorious not once but twice
you know i don't think anyone saw this
coming and just one month after beating
john cena at summerslam
here's what went
down champion the universal champion
going at it
for the first time in two years the
tribal chief himself roman reigns made a
triumphant return to monday night raw
this quite frankly is a huge
huge deal
after roman joined up with tag team
champions the usos they went on to
defeat big e and his new day teammates
[Applause]
roman later came face to face with big e
for a second time that night converging
with bobby lashley for a triple threat
main event where once again roman got to
throw his hand up high
cover one two three and the universal
champion reigns again
yep roman has been on a bit of a winning
streak while defending his title as
universal champion even amid some
serious smack talk
is there one person out there you want
to get in the ring
the one person right right in front of
me roman reigns for summerslam i think
uh people aren't ready for for what
summerslam means especially to me and i
know uh roman reigns isn't ready to hear
it so i'm really surprised or i'm really
i'm really happy and uh
that i get a chance to to say why this
this match is very special
oof sorry john roman proved he was ready
to hear it and just like that roman
reigns will retain the championship john
also told et that he would love to see
roman's cousin you know dwayne the rock
johnson returned to his roots someday i
heard that you are a big advocate of the
rock coming back too have you called him
have you talked to him at all about this
making it happen so i don't think
he
he's earned the right not to be
pressured into that choice i can say
he's a fan of the wwe he's the most
electrifying man in sports entertainment
so as a fan do i want to see one of the
greatest performers in all time step
back in a wwe ring yeah but in no way am
i going to call him and if i'm going to
talk to him about something it's not
going to try to be to get him back in
the wwe ring he needs to come to that
conclusion by himself
as for roman the man isn't slowing down
he'll be competing in the wwe event
extreme rules on sunday
[Music]